they should be right
okay uh so hello everyone welcome to
uh the last day of our workshop on rl
from
simulation batch data so uh our first
speaker today
xiaomi is a visiting
assistant professor at cornell
university in the school of
questions research and information
engineering and before that he spent
two years as a postdoc at leeds and mit
and she has also been a research fellow
at salmon institute
i think several years before so uh
charmian has worked a lot
on network theory stochastic analysis
applied probability and recently she did
very impressive work
on theoretical reinforcement learning
should i get started yeah go ahead uh
thank you mondi
for the invitation and the nice
introduction
uh it's my greatest project to speak at
least exciting workshop
today i'm going to talk about recent
work on reinforcement learning
we unbanked it estate space this is
doing work
with davasha and this issue from mit
we know reinforcement learning is about
the study of sequential decision making
well an agent interacts with possibly
unknown
system and the goal is to gain the
long-term reward
recently it has achieved remarkable
empirical success in many applications
meanwhile there has been a lot of
progress
on the theory side by now
we have a good understanding of
algorithms
for settings refinanced or compacts the
state space
however for province do we unbounded
state space
it is the much less understood
there has been some water considered
such setting but
typically assumes the special structures
for instance the c it is the linear
quadratic system
or the system has the low dimensional
structure
such as linear feature spaced or has the
later model
in this talk i will focus on the
unbounded state space setting
but without such structural assumptions
i will start three unqueuing examples to
highlight
the charges here and then i will
introduce
the uh formulation and moved on to our
approach to tackle the challenges
and i will end the talk with some
extension of our approach
including an adaptive diversion and a
simple efficiency version
our interest in this setting is the
primary motivated about a classical
scheduling province
for a queuing system and a queuing model
typically has to infinites the buffers
leading to an unbounded state space
here is just a simple example through a
single server
and the two queues jobs arrived at each
queue
stochastically at some rate and
the server here we assume that at each
time
the the server can serve at most one job
either from q1 or from q2 if they
serving a job
from q1 then the job will leave the
system
will probably up with probability mu 1
at the end of the time slot
and the similarities therefore for q2
here
for such a system the states can
actually be described
by the vector of the q length here
and we can see the state space stays
unbounded
with two dimensional non-negative
integers
and whenever the server becomes idle
it needs to make a scheduling decision
about
which queues to serve so in the language
of
mdp we have two actions here either q1
or q2
and we are interested in learning uh
scheduling decisions
purely from data without knowing the
system's
uh dynamics and the goal here
is to find a policy that's optimized
some given the criteria for instance
uh minimizing average or this concrete
occurrence
which is a common ghost in queueing
literature
reinforcements limits the perfect
framework
for such a learning task however
due to the unbounded state space
directory applying
existing reinforcement learning
algorithm might not work
for instance the one thing we can do is
to try
the classical offline training and then
deploy approach
here means that you can run your
favorite algorithms
say q learning and you will typically
you will do the training only using
finite samples
and then deploy to the learn the policy
without
further changing the system now
things do we only use the finite samples
for simplicity say
the blue region here contains all the
states
visited during the training phase and
now we know for
a queuing system with randomness the
systems
will visit some states that are not
observed in the training phase
say a yellow state here with some
positive probability
and for such an observed state
the previously trained policy
might not behave well for instance they
might keep serving an ftq while the rq
is large then the number of jobs starts
accumulating in the system so this is
not desirable therefore
online training is the necessary here
but online training i mean we will help
us
the learning algorithm have the ability
to update the policy whenever a new
stage
is encountered
another challenging is about quantifying
how good an
our algorithm is traditionally
we asked for a good performance over the
entire
state space for instance the arrow
metric
in for value function is typically in r
infinity norm
over the state space however
such metric is not feasible
when the state space stays unbounded
since the most of the states are never
visited
or they are far away from visited states
so there is no much information we can
gain from the previous
training so we need an
alternative to to quantify
the goodness here to this end
we use the stability that's motivated
by the queen literature and the control
theory
in the context of queuing system
you know stability means the currents
are finite three probability one
or equivalency is it means the
underlying markov chain is the positive
recurrence funding
optimal control is actually quite
challenging for
manicuring systems so stability
is usually a highly desirable goal here
and it's provide a first step towards
optimality leaving some sense
so inspired by list we
generalize the notion of stability
uh to or from queuing systems to generic
markov decision process to quantify the
goodness of algorithms and similar to
queuing system
intuitively stability here means we want
to maintain the system states
in favorable region and as the approved
or concept
we uh proposed an algorithm that is
stable and we can also characterized as
the sample complexity
to formally states the results
let me start through the setup here
we consider an infinite horizon
discounted mdp
we unbounded state space and the finite
action space
now for a policy a stochastic policy
that's the map each state to a
distribution of
action space we can define the q
function
as usual and similarly we denote q star
as the optimal q functions for the mtp
here
now uh let me uh introduce the stability
notion we are interested here
in formally we want the stability
to incorporate to two properties
which are actually quite common in
stable queuing systems
the first one is bondness
which kind of like mimic finite currents
so intuitively it means that
most of the time the system stays in a
boundary
region here or in other words the
probability of visiting
these small states is quite high
the second one is the recurrence
which kind of like mimic the property of
positive recurrence
basically it says if occasionally
the system states with a sound state
outside the blue region here say a
yellow stage here
then it has the ability to recover
from such undesirable states and
returns to the attraction region
within the finite time steps so
is a high level idea about the
properties of stability we hoped for
now based on the idea here we can
formally
uh define the stability for policy
we will call a policy sequence here
stable
if it satisfies the foreign two
conditions
basically just a mathematical expression
of the two properties
i just introduced and it just means that
with high probability
the system will remain in a boundary
region here
and the for any state the time
to return this boundary to region the
expected time
is actually finite
so if uh you might notice that
the definition here is actually
quite similar to the standard definition
of positive three currents of
time homogeneous demarco chain that
uh i want to point out the key
difference here is
we do allow the policy sequenced here
to be non-stationary so in order to
incorporate the learning
on the fly so the resulting markov chain
can be
timed in homogeneous so
you can view our definition here is
generalizations due to in homogeneous
markov chain for the notion of
recurrence
okay so now the questions
we are interested here is
how can we learn a stable policy purely
from data
for such an amban data space setting
our approach is based on among the
current simulation and the search method
the key components in our algorithm
is uh monte carlo oracle
so the oracle will take a single state
so this is important as we only take a
single stage
as the input and it will output
a probability distribution over the
uh action space so you can
understand the probability distribution
here
as an approximate optimal policy
or approximates the policy for the query
states
s and we assume that
this oracle has access to a simulator
so meaning for each stage action pair
we can generate the samples the next
days
according to the transition kernel and
the immediate
reward so
i will come back to more details on the
implementation of this article later
now with this oracle the overall
algorithm our oro algorithm work as
follows
so starting stuff on the initial stage
as
zero here at each time step
the algorithm will first query the
mc oracle to obtain the probability
distribution
of actions and then it will take an
action
according to the suggestion and the
system makes
transitions to the next stage
and then it will repeat this process
so basically the algorithm is quite
simple
it's the key components as i say is the
magdakar oracle
and which kandarai gives the suggestion
about which actions to play for each
single staged
arrangement now
ideally we hope that the
mc oracle can give us the optimal
policy for each query state
but this is too good to be true in
reality
this is almost impossible without
knowing the system model
so now our hope here is
what if the mc oracle can
outpost a policy that's close to
the optimal one for each query state in
some sense
and if the system is stable under the
optimal policy then maybe we are able to
claim
stability of the uh approximate
policy sequence and that's the hope here
moreover we uh ideally we want these
mc oracles uh to compute
such an approximate optimal policy for
each query
space by only using finite examples
as i mentioned ideally once this
algorithm can be fully online
so if we can obtain such an approximate
policy
by only using finite sample then that is
hoped of implementation
i will pause here in case there's any
questions
about the algorithms here
all clear over here okay uh good
now let me continue so as i mentioned
our
hope here is the mc oracle it can
output approximate policy by only using
finite samples
and indeed there's two or a methods that
can surface go
one is the spa sampling oracle and
the other one is the monte carlo 3
search
which has been widely used in many games
including avago
and avago 0 last beast human champion
so both oracles consist of two main
steps here
first we are going to use multi-steps
look-ahead simulations
to estimate the optimum q value
for the query states s
and then based on estimated q value
we will construct a soft max or
so-called
box map policy as for us
here the how an important parameter
is tau here typically is called the
temperature parameter
so we can see if for high temperature
tau if relaxed tau goes to infinity
then the distribution here becomes the
uniform
and for low temperature tau for tau that
is close to zero then the policy here
becomes greedy with respects to
the q function estimates so it's kind of
important to choose an appropriate style
let's kind of encourage some exploration
and the randomness
and the from the overall approach here
we can see
the key step is about estimating the
optimal q function
for the query states due to time
constraint i won't get
into details here so the high
level idea of the estimation basically
is you can think about this as
multi-steps to value iteration
but by using uh simulations
and we only focused on a single state
for
the query states here so let's
difference the from
the classical value iteration procedure
now for the q function approximation
for spa sampling oracle it has been
shown stressed
with proper parameters the estimates
can actually be close to the optimal q
function
with high probability
empirically mcts is more efficient
and recently we are able to establish
a rigorous theoretical guarantee which
is as
this as good as the spartan marine
now with the guarantee own estimates q
function
we can obtain an upper bound on
the difference between the
resulting stock max policy mu here and
the optimal policy for a query state
so you can ignore the expression here so
the key message
here is the upper bound on the policy
difference
can actually be small if we have a small
arrow bound
on the q function and a small
temperature parameter type
now of course a natural question here
is how small the arrow bound should be
in order to achieve the stability
and what's the corresponding
corresponding sample complexity
per queries for oracle
now to answer these two questions let me
first
introduce an assumption we need here
so suppose that the markov chain
under the optimal policy is not stable
in queuing system this means the system
road is above the system capacity
then there is no policy can make the
system stable and there is no hope of
learning one
so the minimum requirements that we have
here
is the optimal policy leads to
a stable system or a positive
recurrence the markov chain now
on the other hand as well knows that
positive
recurrence is equivalent to the
existence of so-called reaction function
so this motivates us to consider
the following assumption here
we assume stats for the markov chain
under the optimal policy there exists a
diagonal function
satisfies the two conditions here
first one the possible change
of the value of the diagonal function
during any
transition is bounded by some constant
and you might be more familiar with the
second condition here on the drift
it says for states such as
the realm function is above some threat
should be
then it admits a negative drift here
this type of assumption is actually
quite standard
in queueing and in control theory
uh indeed saturday after function exists
for managing systems for
example the for the two server or two
queue example we have seen earlier is
well known fast
the optimal policy is actually the
so-called simian rule
and the ukrainian uh norm of the state
is actually a diablo function that
satisfies the least assumption
and i want to point out stress our
algorithm does not need to know
the exactly abnormal function
so based on uh under east
diagonal assumption now with proper
guarantee
from the mcr call the resulting
policy sequence is actually stable
the stable is the notion we introduced
earlier
so here if strong corresponding
to the error bound for the q function
from the mc oracle and again
tau here the temperature tile uh is
for the soft max policy and
the minus alpha here is the negative
drift
of the the optimal function so
we can see basically it says as long as
the error
and the temperature is more enough
then the policy sequence are stable
of course you might wonder without
knowing the system although the optimal
function how can we
ensure the parameter that
if strong and how to be small enough
uh i will come back to this question
later
uh so now we when we have we set the
temperature tau
to be tau alpha which scales through uh
the drift of the outbound function in in
this
order then the sample complexity is
actually
finite in particular the
sample complexity per query scales
as follows so
now it's good we have the stability
results and
we can the approximate policy can be
computed by only using finite samples
um i think okay i still have enough
times to cover a little bit
about the pro so here i will briefly
uh discuss the proof outlines for the
stability and the sample complexity
results
uh it consists of three main steps the
first step is
to show that the monte carlo oracle
uh can actually output approximate
new optimal policy with high probability
and we have downgraded for spa sampling
oracle and mcts
and the second step is to perform drift
analysis
for the markov chain under approximate
policy sequence
in particular we can show that the
markov chain
can admit a diagonal function that
satisfies
similar drift condition as the optimal
policy
of course with different uh constants
and based on the drift condition then we
were used
results by bruce kayak to finish his
stability analysis
so now let me uh come back to our
results
here so as i say in order to
achieve stability the parameter
temperature tile
should be small enough and of course
in principle we can use a very very
small towel
but notice that a small towel means the
small arrow bound
for the mc oracle and intuitively
such a small error requirements will
induced
high sample complexity so we want the
temperature tile to be small enough but
not too small
for for efficiency and the best choice
is tau over here that's depends
on the drift condition
and now the question here is
uh without knowing the diagonal function
or the drift condition can we find an
proper value for the temperature tile
automatically
so this is the first question and
another question
is about the sample complexity here
even with the optimal temperature tau
value here
the sample complexity actually you can
observe that is the super polynomial
in one over alpha so it becomes the
highly inefficient
when alpha is the small so for
you guys if you are familiar with
queuing system
uh a small alpha corresponding to
typically
uh corresponding to high load origin
and we know analyzing queuing system in
this region will
allows us to understand some fundamental
performance the bottleneck
so it's highly desirable to have an
efficient algorithm still for this
regime as well
indeed we have extension of our
algorithms to handle
both of these two issues in particular
we have a simple efficiency version
that's actually based on
a more simple efficient or mc oracle
such as the complexity now instead of
super polynomial it becomes polynomial
dependence on one over alpha here
and here d is the dimension of the state
space
and for the uh
we also have an adaptive version that
can discover
an appropriate tuning parameter tau
automatically and the key idea here
is to carefully construct this
statistical hypothesis testing as the
rules to determine whether we should
change the
we should reduce the tuning parameter
tower or not
uh due to time constraint i i don't have
time
to get into details here so let me
wrap that here uh we consider arrow for
setting the unbounded state space and
introduce the notion of stability
and have an online algorithm that is
stable
moving forward that actually requires
some interesting future directions
and so if you have seen that so this one
even
it's a simple efficiency version we can
see it still has
an exponential dependence on dimension b
and to break the cursor dimensionality
it's important to explore a problem
structure
for function approximation and
another question here is as in queueing
system
stability usually is only the first step
towards optimality
then a natural next question is can we
develop an algorithm that achieves the
stronger performance guarantee
so that's all i want to say today
uh thank you all for your attention and
this talk is mainly based on two
of our recent papers i'm happy to take
questions
great any questions in q a
well i guess i i have um a comment and a
question so
i enjoyed your talk it's awesome um
the uh i mean first is to comment the
boundedness of the increments of l
implies geometric ergodicity i don't
know if you notice that it might be
useful
and the other thing is if you double l
you double
alpha so how do you how do you uniquely
define alpha
so that's a very interesting question
actually someone asked me about this
question
and it's turned out even if you cannot
proportionally scale that error and then
during the phone analysis you can see
somehow these effects
was uh uh kind of like cancel out
uh from the analysis and this means
even if you scale the counter uh
the diagonal function it doesn't helps
to use to scale the requirements
for the trees but what's the definition
of alpha because i can always make alpha
one
whatever whatever whatever if you give
me a layout of the function l
i'll divide it by alpha and then my
drift is always one
so okay um that's a good point
uh i need to think of our s
right uh yeah
maybe an interest of time we could
continue and then um perhaps later for
the panel discussion
people want to see some questions
thank you for the for the talk um uh
stefan do you want to go ahead and try
to share your screen
sure um i'll stop against